if it makes you feel better I cried all
over my shirt tonight watching your mom
perform I mean it's true I really cried
I didn't know and I and I do cry easily
these days but I did not know I wouldn't
be able to stop I think and now I wasn't
nervous for my dance but I was crying
through it and I was like but I was
thank you for being there I love you and
now they are ready to perform
one last
time
[Music]
you know what summer you're gonna watch
this clip back and also see the reaction
from your fellow cast members everyone
was overcome with emotion because as
they said you are a light in this
competition how much are you gonna miss
them
that's why I cry I mean I'm not crying
about a mirror at all I have so much
better than a mirror ball here and
Miss
this
I will miss loving them
I love these dancers I love these
celebrities I love Sasha I love her
rehearsal room I mean it's just it's
it's a lot of love and to walk away to
have to let the love continue without
you it's like oh
you know but you were such an
inspiration I was telling Sasha I feel
inspired just watching you and and you
made such an impact in such a short
amount of time but I want to know why it
was important for you guys to do this
last dance tonight knowing that you're
gonna bow out early
you know I started on a waltz and I
remember I could barely even like he'd
show me a step and it was like Hey
backwards like my body would really
seize up and I have come so far also
physically I don't even have clonus in
my left leg now like it's a I have like
a not so much of a drop but I've I've
strengthened some muscles I mean tonight
I just happen to be a little shaky
because I just got a little stiff with
some muscle stuff but
I I have so much improvement despite
some kind of injury stuff happening but
it's like I have so much improvement I'm
so I'm so much better and I would have
never had the motivation to push myself
in that way if it weren't for this kind
of thing with Sasha or Sasha I mean
there's so much love and support coming
your guys's way we actually just spoke
with Rhys tonight I've been following
her journey on Instagram and of course
watching the show and she's just so she
just she's such a dancer anyway so it's
wonderful to see her having such a fun
time I love that girl so much I mean
what a superstar what does it mean to
have your friends and family rally
around you during this time I mean it's
everything I've got it it's everything
it's what we we all hope there could be
Silver Linings in every disappointment
and it has been such an overwhelming
Silver Lining to feel this love and to
feel the people that I admire most in
this business or in this room or or
having nothing to do with dancing people
just showing up and being supportive of
me and the fellow you know everyone here
oh yeah it breaks her heart open it does
Arthur how proud are you of your mom I'm
really proud of my
um yeah thank you Sasha how much you're
gonna miss dancing with Selma
oh we're taking this to all the
elementary schools yeah we're gone one
and eight L.A USC tour no I'm just
kidding but we we talk about it I'm like
okay well I'm a little rickety now for a
while but when we get back on we're
gonna get we're gonna mop it up at the
public schools in my dreams I think
listen I think uh summer will be a
little busy filming some major movies
yeah
thank you